delphine raconte-nous ce qui s'est passé
parce que c'est vrai qu'on s'est tous
inquiétés toute la bande ce week-end
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce week end
alors après mamma longues semaines à
paris du lundi au vendredi je suis
arrivé en gare de mulhouse à 22 heures
tu rentrais chez moi et là je me suis
dit ben pour finir la semaine j'aimerais
manger un petit truc donc du coup je
suis descendu ça te fait rire déjà
mulhouse forcément de se régler cédant
patin mais ne
s'est pas l'humoriste aura pas le fou
j'étais fier je suis très fier de ma
fille
c'est pas le sujet vrai qu'on est fiers
de mulhouse et où les maisons en pierre
de mulhouse c'est mulhouse en 2012 nous
avons donc du coup on se re
contextualise vendredi soir après une
longue semaine intensive 22 heures je
vais chercher un plat de pâtes donc je
descends de chez moi et je vais au
restaurant à 50 m je viens 50 m quant à
toi tu es là je me jeu je rentre chez
moi en vrai ben c'est à 50 mètres
c'était à aller 15 secondes voilà donc
je commence avec mon plat de pâtes je
rentre je cours et là je commence à
courir et il ya un mec qui vient à côté
de moi commence à courir à côté de moi
maintenant ces charmantes et ou machin
c'est ok super je suis poli avec lui je
lui réponds un peulh et à mon code donc
ça va très très vite s'arrêter et là il
me dit c'est quoi ton numéro c'est quoi
ton prennent la vedette de l'inviter
oui non oui oui bon je recontextualise
j'ai fait mon code et à ce moment là et
à ce moment là il me dit est ce que tu
veux que je te montre est ce que tu
aimes bien le foot je fais non mais là
j'ai pas le temps allez bonne soirée et
tous les faits à temps je te montre un
truc de foot là il me prend juste par la
main il fait à temps je te montre un
truc qui se tient à moi mais en fait
j'ai l'habitude mois qu'on me combe
touche le bras et tout donc ça ne m'a
pas vraiment gêné et là il me prend la
main il fatto je te montre un truc et là
ils commencent à sauter à côté de moi et
avec son pied il commence à me donner
des genres de deux petits de petits
coups dans les pieds et c'est là que je
dis non mais non mais là stop arrête
voilà après il fait semblant de tomber
hockey est en fait après quand il repart
en titubant voilà ça s'arrête je fais
mon code je rentre chez moi et entre
temps il ya des jeunes qui m'ont dit ça
va mademoiselle et vous avez impliqué je
dis non je vais pas mon téléphone tout
va bien je rentre chez moi je veux enfin
manger mais pas de finir ma semaine là
je vais enlever ma montre et j'ai plus
ma montre en fait donc le gars voilà
j'ai rien demandé à personne je voulais
finir ma semaine je vais donner mon
respect je lui ai répondu je lui ai
parlé et le gars il me salit il me vole
mon truc et en un tour de passe passe du
coup j'ai vraiment envie de rappeler aux
gens parce que je ne le savais pas et en
fait quand les gens font ça quand ils
vous touchez qui vous font des trucs
dans les violences c'est pour les
montres quand ils vous font un autre
truc une autre corps et c'est pour ce
qui est dans la poche arrière quand ils
vous demandent le chemin en même temps
faisant comme ça c'est pour vous voler
la bandoulière et toutes ces choses là
on ne le sais pas moi si je l'avais su
le gars qui commence à me trifouiller
dans les pieds j'aurais su que c'était
pour ma montre mais j'ai pas pensé en
fait c'était devant chez moi au t2
devant chez moi à 22h et en fait ça me
il m'est jamais rien arrivé parce que
dès qu'il y avait le début d'un
commencement un peu des trucs un peu
bizarres
les gens me reconnaissent hélas après
ils me laissent tranquille ça m'est déjà
arrivé plein de fois au final il me
laisse tranquille et ce gars là ce
vendredi ne m'a pas reconnue et j'ai eu
le traitement de bas de toutes les
femmes qui ne peuvent plus marcher en
fait dans la rue le soir mois plein de
fois je vais me promener mon chien 2
heures du matin tôt je ne le ferai plus
je le ferai plus j'ai vraiment eu peur
je suis dégoûté quand j'étais jeune on
m'a toujours appris ne fait pas
confiance aux inconnus fait attention
faut pas monter avec n'importe qui en
voiture bien sûr et puis après en
grandissant ce 10 mai en fait la
personne est une inconnue à partir du
moment où on lui parle elle est plus
inconnu donc ouvrons-nous un peu en
grandissant je me suis ouvert aux autres
mais en fait faut pas avoir peur des
gens fait c'est faux aujourd'hui en
france à avoir peur des gens on vous
sent très très choqués ont
choqué je suis je suis dégoûté et mi
temps quand vous êtes tout à fait sains
et en fait effectivement alors on m'a
dit oui mais c'est que une montre alors
pour vous dire effectivement il ya une
semaine j'étais à genève je me suis fait
faire une jolie monde j'ai passé une
journée avec un horloger on a fait cette
montre ensemble je les fais moi même
elle est unique j'avais pas envie de la
faire voler en fait oui mais tu t'es pas
fait agresser physiquement mais une
richard mille donc en fait elle est
unique donc effectivement on peut la
retrouver mais moi j'ai rien demandé je
n'avais pas envie de donner cette montre
à ce gala j'ai travaillé pour cette
montre je suis désolé je devais pas me
la faire voler en 10 secondes dehors
devant devant chez moi
et donc alors donc derrière après mais
du coup d'état j'ai même pas comment
faire en fait j'appelle même pas le 17
le premier truc que je fais je vais avec
mes potes et je fais le tour de mulhouse
pour voir si je retrouve cette paix
parce que voilà j'ai pas le réflexe tout
de suite je mets sur install com voilà
ce qui s'est passé je suis dégoûté et
tout j'espère avec ce message là
retrouver les deux jeunes qui ont été
témoins en même temps ils vont pas mal
je venais exception je viens de me faire
agresser dans la rue en un tour de passe
passe ma montre a disparu marre de ce
pays que fait la police nous avons
tourné une heure pour retrouver mon
agresseur et nous n'avons pas vu une
seule patrouille de police pendant tout
ce temps donc là là c'est vrai que c'est
ça qui a fait énormément agir aussi et
au final j'appelle pas du tout le 17
j'appelle deux personnes que je connais
qui sont à la police je leur écris sur
messenger et je le redis je me suis fait
voler ma montre qu'est ce que je fais
est ce que j'attends lundi pour porter
plainte ils m'ont dit maintenant mais
delphine le premier truc tu appelles le
17 et oui tout de suite tout de suite
mais moi je ne savais pas il ya deux
victimes de votre feria vous et la
police fait alors je syndicats de police
alors justement remontés comme des
pendules alors justement alliance police
nationale grand messe des morts une
polémique stérile suite au message de
défi le décideur sur les réseaux sociaux
après le vol à la tire de sa montre à
son poignet sans violence à mulhouse
voilà à peine que l' enquête sur le vol
de la montre se poursuit et quand on
entend un attendant les services de
police se tiennent à l'entière
disposition delphine wespiser ils ont
été extrêmement triste de voir la
réaction delphine des spider et va ils
ont été déçus bah oui la police fait
partie des victimes de ce que tu
racontes effectivement voir tu t'es
peintes sur les réseaux sociaux alors
que c'était simple de faire sur le
clavier de 17 pour appeler la police
c'est c'est hyper regrettable et encore
une fois je trouve que on tape sur la
police évidemment il faut savoir que ce
genre de chose que tu as vécu c'est un
million de fois par an enfin mais comme
les téléphones et c'est donc la police
effectivement fait des procédures fait
des recherches le problème des
pickpockets il y en a partout pour les
retrouver c'est quasiment impossible
mais ce qui est dommage vraiment très
dommage c'est d'avoir jeté l'opprobre
sur la pole est la priorité évidemment
j'ai un certain qui se se met à danser
vous regrettez votre but en 10 ans alors
qu'en fait mon poste un stage l'effet
sur le coup de j'étais choqué dégoûté
j'ai écrit ça est en fait cette phrase
que fait la puce c'est une phrase que
toutes les victimes peuvent dire mars
qu'en fait quand il nous arrive ça on
aimerait la solution instantanée la
police devant nous en tant elle pouvait
pas être devant moi je ne vais pas
appeler donc voila c'était et puis au
final je me suis demandé et on s'est
beaucoup écrit ce week-end je me suis
dit pourquoi est ce que sa mère moi je
diffuse de la bienveillance j'essaye de
travailler dur
arrive effectivement à tout le monde
n'importe où le même devant sa porte et
ensuite je me suis dit en fait ça mais
peut-être arrivé pour pouvoir répondre à
cette question que fait la police eh ben
j'ai vu ce qu'elle a fait la police
puisque j'ai passé toute la nuit au
commissariat j'ai parlé avec eux j'ai vu
que si j'ai pas vu la police dans les
rues à mulhouse c'est parce que vous
avez plein plein de voitures banalisées
oui les boss enfin bloqué et les gens ne
le savent pas j'ai vu des gens hyper
engagé hyper courageux et tout et je
pense que aujourd'hui
les gens ne légitiment plus autant la
police parce que vous allez vous avez
pas assez de moyens vous n'avez pas
assez de personnes nous faudrait
vraiment parce qu'effectivement il ya
les victimes de l'insécurité c'est les
gens et c'est aussi la police parce
qu'aujourd'hui la justice devrait pas
plus de moyens si on si le si on
retrouve le vin qui a récupéré ma montre
la police est un levier pour la
population des rats mais alors des
récidivistes tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps et au final
voilà ce que j'avais vécu là les
policiers des chiffres c'est important
de le dire c'est 3 millions
d'interventions par an c'est à dire
toutes les dix secondes là on est sur le
plateau toutes les dix secondes la
police règle un problème en france c'est
des violences avec vol sans violence vol
avec violence agressions sur des femmes
bref tout ce qu'on peut imaginer en
termes de délits c'est la première fois
que vous faites un travail qui est
considérable que ce produit est la
première fois il y avait eu il y avait
eu des débuts de commencement comme
comme ouais mais c'est beaucoup de ces
malheureux d'avoir 7,7 cette réflexion
franchement moi j'ai eu des collègues
tout après midi mais de sécu ou qui elle
se prend quand même match non je vois
dieu sait que je défends la police et
des corps et à vraiment je suis sûr
toujours toujours derrière la police
après il faut juste reconnaître que on
le voit partout sur les vidéos toute la
journée maintenant les vols de montres
et de bijoux dans paris pour parler que
de paris prononcé à l'aja bitar to say
say say say quotidien plus personne ne
porte de mon temps on a peur tout le
monde a peur tout n'apparaît pas
complètement mais c'est vrai vous avez
vu sur internet les vols y en a partout
sur tous les sites médias et tout ça
c'est comment comment expliquer qu'ils
ont autant autant autant attendu
aujourd'hui dans des prisons il bosse
sur le sénat et dieu sait si l'enfant du
du crâne comme on dit ils vont chercher
les boyaux problème c'est qu'il ya de
plus en plus devient conseiller tout ça
il faut le traiter j'étais tout à
l'heure au téléphone avec linda kebab
qui vous salue bien géré mais lindahl
crois qu'elle croit que j'aime pas alors
j'ai rien contre l avenir est remonté
pour notre sujet je sais mais elle se
disait tout à l'heure avec la fait bien
avant qu'elles veulent une d'argent je
sais bien je dis d'ailleurs et et pour
dire qu' il manque de moyens dans la
police humain ça c'est certain mais en
même temps quand on traite des
procédures comme la vôtre on shoppe
l'individu qui a piqué le montre
téléphone c'est toujours trop évidemment
ça prend deux trois heures aux policiers
véreux il parle des écrits etc c'est
légal quand ils sont là ils sont pas
sûrs donc il ya des procédures qui sont
mises en place maintenant avec le bruit
de la sécurité heureusement mais en même
temps la police ne peut pas régler
toutes les problèmes de la société
choisissez un million de vols par an
c'est pas rien et c'est pour ça encore
une fois permettez moi de vous dire
allez sur les réseaux et puis et
rectifier si vous avez aimé parce que
alors je alors est-ce que vous allez
rectifier ce que vous aviez sur les
réseaux obtenir ce matin je me suis
réveillée et j'ai vu qu effectivement la
police me demande de faire des excuses
aujourd'hui mon but c'est pas du tout de
faire des excuses étant donné que déjà
il ya deux jours on en a parlé ensemble
cyril moi j'ai attendu lundi pour vous
dire ça c'est pas des excuses parce que
j'ai la pression c'est parce que vous le
savez et tous les gens qui regardent
l'émission je suis tout faire pour
l'ordre je suis hyper pour pour eux pour
la police pour les pompiers à chaque
fois je vous défendre ce dérapage mais
c'est pas un dérapage c'est sur le coup
de l'émotion
besoin d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux
oui bon dire je fais la police frise les
50 on se fait voler on va faire une main
courante dans un commissariat
à moment donné bon les gens vont faire
le beau le travail mais c'est à peu de
chance quand même qu'on retrouve thamond
sauf que là c'est un peu je tiens tu
oses de sa célébrité à les interpeller
les gens surtout qu'on est dans un
hammam est la raison et émotion et ma
forme est là tuez moi
c'est facile vous avez fait la police
mais mais vous savez que vous allez
mettre ça a été vexé par ce pass est
allé parce que je dis il m'est arrivé ça
je pense pour qu'au final je puisse
répondre à cette question que tous les
français disent tout le temps il dit à
la police qu'il fallait rouler de fumer
mais la police et c'est ça que je veux
dire parce que je les ai vues de mes
propres yeux pendant la nuit la police
travaillent les mois je suis fier
d'avoir une police comme ça en france
qui est partout le même si on ne la voit
pas mais pour que la police ait un
mieux-être et pour que les gens aiment
mieux-être il faut que la justice soit
plus sévère
s'est pas laissée à noter
jusqu'à policier a été a été triste mais
était triste de de scud de votre pays
c'est ça maintenant à quoi on parle a ce
sentiment je comprends mais je pense
qu'il m'est arrivé c'est la victime la
victime s'est elle à l'arrivée aux siens
oui la victime c'est tout le monde avec
les millions de gens qui se sont roulés
ne vont pas sur les réseaux sociaux
dirais que fait la police c'est ça le
truc c'est jésus comme les divisions
n'est pas d'accord avec avec le nom mais
s'ils voulaient se m'amuse parce que on
parle de polémique mais qui a déclenché
la polémique
fuir c'est une victime qui a abandonné
sur la tête choc elle utilise un moyen
d'expression qui est celui qui est là à
portée de main alors c'est un réseau
social ok mais ça aurait pu être
complètement autre chose elle dit juste
que fait la police et une question est
là pouf tout le monde s'emballe le
syndicat alliance commence à délirer sur
yon pays réagissent à dos reis et ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle un état de choc
juste un état de choc et si on évitait
toujours précisément la polémique sur
n'en veut pas eh ben on évite doit
déclencher sa ses premiers points en
l'occurrence effectivement moi j'ai une
victime quand je vous entends dire
monsieur qui a deux victimes la police
la victime abonnés moi mais pour une
mission des vidéos tu as des cultures
cherchez vous avez la parole facile je
mets invite à passer une nuit avec la
bac comme ça monsieur je veux dire
combien d'aces que ce que j'ai dit à
mathieu je veux dire je ne sais pas moi
qu'il faut dire ça je parlais de kobe ne
l'aurait pas meilleur soutien que moi
ils parlent tous les sujets comme s'ils
connaissent et savent ce que je connais
qu'est ce que c'est je connais je veux
dire en l'occurrence effectivement la
différence de goût c'est que j'étale pas
ma vie sur des plateaux monsieur mais en
l'occurrence amidon ne pas coûter
monsieur monsieur je mettrais qu'à la
catégorie générale et c'est précieux et
à propos qui est de dire effectivement
que en l'occurrence je dire on a une
victime qui est sous le choc et qui
utilisent un moyen d'expression ensuite
un syndicat de police trouve nécessaire
de reprendre les propos qu'elle a bien
sûr ces dernières années ils ont droit
mais elle a le droit aussi mais nos
ventes du monde annonce n'a pas le droit
non un peu ce qu'on apprécie bon bah
voilà mais non mais là vous avez pas la
police peut être monsieur lévy mais
monsieur je veux dire en l'occurrence
team en france que vous ne comprenez pas
je ne prenais pas dans cette affaire
c'est que nous ne sommes pas sur le même
plan nous avons affaire à quelqu'un qui
a été victime d'une agression qui réagit
sur le coup je veux dire voilà points
elle se contente de gérer les policiers
sont victimes toute l'année
auteur dycker menu laquelle il voulait
non j'ai pas dû comprendre toute
l'histoire parce que au final ce lundi à
l'histoire c'est une demande que fait la
police sans l'avoir appelée
j'entends pas l'habitude en fait ce sont
les malades
et que fait la police qu'elle était
allée elle a tourné avec ses potes pour
retrouver le ga ga l'a pas vu une
patrouille de la police à tourner à
alger 24 dans ta rue jeudi sur la
toile après est ce que j'essaye de vous
dire c'est qu'en fait on est absolument
dans le même camp et que moi je soutiens
la police et je l' ai toujours dit et
que la gérer le temps de jeu lent mais
justement je réponds publiquement à
cette question que je me suis posée que
tous les français parfois peuvent se
poser quand ils sont en situation où ils
veulent une réponse immédiate que fait
la police mais j'ai vu ce que fait la
police et c'est super et aujourd'hui
vous avez besoin de plus de moyens pour
que vous vous soyez plus à l'aise et
nous on se sent plus en sécurité turques
qui est des réserves non j'ai c'était en
fait je pense que ma mission en fait
c'était ça il m'est arrivé ça peut-être
pour pouvoir parler de ce sujet là
surtout je le répète lorsqu'on vous
touche l'ours vous touche les pieds
c'est qu'on veut votre
envie d'entendre la tuer c'est ça c'est
malheureux ce qui arrive à delphi de ses
traits c'est triste c'est une agression
tu as travaillé pour cette montre moi
j'ai envie de dire à delphine tient bien
bienvenue dans le monde des grands
dans le centre-ville grand ami de
montres à plus de 20000 ou 30 min 48 je
ne sais pas j'en sais rien 10000 euros
s'ils lui ont volé ce n'est pas pour la
revendre 5 euros 50 cibles ont volé
c'est qu'ils savaient pourquoi ils vont
voler ils l'ont vu descendre du train et
il ya des codes c'est con à dire mais à
des codes quand tu dis dans le métro
tout le monde dans l'axé maintenant les
gens dans le métro on lève pas leur nom
gare de remonter on leur vole pas leur
montre si son parti cible et delphine
parce qu'il savait très bien que
derrière il avait la revendre c'est
comme on entend ce moment des brigades
sur paris qui s'amusent il peut nous le
dire monsieur pommard qui s'amusent à
prendre des montres à 50 60 70 mille
euros y'a des gens qui se font
cambrioler les gens qui se font prendre
leurs voitures aux feux rouges c'est
horrible les gens il rentre chez toi ils
classent tous chez toi avec cambriole
pourquoi c'est encore plus récents
encore plus dur là ce que j'ai envie de
dire à delphine c'est grave à la raison
mais de s'emporter comme ça de dire
marre de ce pays malheureusement tu es
bancaire qui arrivait dans la vie de
tous les jours est arrivé à 22h dans une
gare avec des gens malveillants la
prochaine montre que tu tu achèteras
quand tu rembourses sera celle-là enlève
malheureusement c'est il est horrible
temps compté
c'est la vie et non pas 20 30 millions
je suis ravi ça tu es de la série pour
les assassins de leurs produits on
disait des femmes attention mettez pas
les jupes les
ficelles et dresse le relais c'est que
ce n'est pas là qu'on veut vivre on peut
aimer la police et reconnaître et dire à
monsieur qu'en même temps on a un
sentiment d'insécurité qui est de plus
en plus grands qui est embêtant mais
quand j'entends dire qu'il a démissionné
toit de ce pays tu dis bah finalement
voile apporter plus de monde portait
plus rien n'est jamais vraiment su
réagir mais leur attention dans la laddh
et le jour elle s'habille s'est
récemment ses six années alors accès à
l'airé de rivoli garçons mais ont
surtout
guillaume genton qui veut parler tout
c'est l'heure pour moi non mais si oui
moi je connais une
femme et j'ai été agressé à plusieurs
appels guillaume genton s'est passé
c'est ça qui me choque moi ce qui me
choque c'est que tu es besoin d'un
événement personnel pour te rendre
compte de ce qu'on voit partout dans les
journaux
il a besoin
c'est normal c'est normal c'est du
désaveu
mais là c'est n'importe quoi ils
savaient ce qu'ils faisaient mais yann
au sénat ne trouve que ça s'est excusé
moi j'ai trouvé que pour la vie que ça
nous arrive des problèmes donc il a
raison bon bah ça devrait passer de
match honnête ça arrivait devant masse
honnête j'ai été à son comble entre donc
en 50 m 2 il ne devait rien trop
rapidement c'est comme ça
bon déjà je suis pas du tout d'accord
les crémont c'est pas aux voleurs vous
agressez pas des films de changer
souvent le réseau anglais aux agrégats
l'avoir portée des mondes mais ensuite
ce qui me gêne c'est la récupération
politique malheureusement qui est fait
autour de ça sert que quand tu mets ça
des filles quand tu mets marre de ce
pays mamane avons malheureusement il ya
des amis des proches de marine le pen
d'eric zemmour qui ont twitté qui ont
repris cette affaire pour en faire de la
récupération politique c'est à dire
qu'on prend un fait divers et on fait de
la politique la politique avec sa
sécurité oui il peut y avoir des faits
divers là je trouve ça gênant c'est un
cas qui peut être isolé il faut pas en
faire des généralités parce qu'après il
peut faire des amalgames chez soi même à
droite
ces bandes armées capable de l'estragon
vous tous qui êtes au top j'avais de
l'impact ont dit j'attends ce prix déjà
annoncé
la police
mais qu on accuse on savait pas en
disant ça mais si tu dis c'est ma plus
belle fille de la seconde les français
ne connaissent pas c'est bien la police
qu'on pense qu'on connaît la police ne
connaît pas la police et en passant la
nuit là-bas j'ai vu j'ai vu ce que
c'était et et j'ai juste envie de dire
qu'effectivement devrait renouer le
dialogue entre entre les gens et la
police parce qu'aujourd'hui on dit oui
de façon les voir que pour le cas sont
les voit que quand on fait un excès de
vitesse maintenant vous nous allons donc
la chose et quand vous n'êtes pas
regretter vos qualités votre poste c'est
ça elle va refermer a préféré laisser
moi vous voulez car ce qu'elle voudra
plus d'audience que sur mon petit
instagram quand même charme et fait le
jeu mais n'ont rien compris décès ni cas
ça leur fera plaisir abbas avait beau
être content oui